beth how are you i'm good i'm so happy
to see you
don't have a human yeah i know another
human
so see your bar is that low you're not
necessarily happy to see conan o'brien
just any human will do
i should have taken that back i've
written i love conan here
on this board in preparation for this
big event i'm sure you can see it
clearly
no no well it's there just trust that
it's there
i wrote it in this marker not permanent
marker
okay all right oops i dropped it you
know
um i'm a big fan of yours uh huge fan of
yours
and we uh have been very anxious at team
coco to support
your stand-up special in any way
possible that's something that's been a
labor of love for us
you know we've really wanted to get the
word out normally i would pay for you to
have a giant best-selling billboard in
times square i'd pay for that out of my
own pocket
gladly but what good you gonna do during
a pandemic
you've employed some novel techniques
like you've you
you've been using my friends and family
to handle some grassroots
marketing efforts yeah
like you had someone write the details
of my special on a sidewalk in chalk
which i mean one thunderstorm and that's
gone conan
i know but look first of all i thought
that four-year-old did a very good job
i think it looked pretty good and yeah
so it'll last until the next rainstorm
but you know what all publicity is good
publicity
okay well-traveled sidewalk
you also had a friend of mine hang a
banner outside of her house
and she lives on a country road so i
just feel like no one
we needed that sign at the smash mouth
concert you know like i just feel like
i need your head i looked into that i
looked into having it hung
at the smash mouth uh concert and people
they said it was unsafe the the people
that hang spines
so that's why they hung it on that rural
country road in north carolina
you even hired my dad the owner and soul
operator of stars on call
in orlando and he had him do a
commercial
that this is actually real
this is your dad your dad did that's my
father
yeah brother let's take a look at this
clip now of your dad promoting
uh girl daddy let's take a look best
elling
girl daddy hbo max
keep smiling and watch it
what's his deal what is the deal with
that man
look he does live roadside commercials
or character directions
so he stands in front of businesses that
are paying him to get people
inside and maybe online
is that and is it work does he i would
think i mean some people
might frighten some people from going
into a into a vision
that's a very valid point um sometimes
he was on the news he was on far out on
fox and they did say
when they asked the business owners that
up to and then they give some sort of
percentage and i don't know how they
reached that percentage uh
but that 75 more people entered than if
or weren't out front so yeah i guess you
could say it's working
i actually have one more request oh yeah
i just feel like
the least you could do for me now is
where this girl that he had that i sent
over to you
to largo this is nice i'll wear this
around
this it's adjustable this will get you'd
better be adjustable because
yeah it no it's actually on the highest
setting
i have a massive skull you have a big
brain
my dad would say my dad always said
because i had a big head it was because
i had a big brain
so i'm going to pass that on to you